appello a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti
questo nuovi dio sono fa vj oggi in
persona nuovamente il padre migliore del
mondo
8 tel eravamo rimasti vabbè tanto lo
vedete buona visione
cerca la pizza congelare per niente cosa
sta succedendo loro mi hanno fatto ma
giorno era mio matrimonio
vabbè ma devo prendere il carrello
mandiamo il carrè va bene in teoria loro
magari vanno all'acquario mentre io
faccio il papà che compra le cose quindi
alla quale io non ci vado
scusatemi che che razza di supermarket
ci voglio andare subito prendi della
soda al mango arrivo sono stato preso in
pieno dal proprio placement posso no no
no no no quelli mi servono sia quelli mi
servono scusa mi sa che mi sta guardando
devo farlo mentre non mi guarda che
bella questa va cum nola loro sto
volando l'abaco un mastro cocktail
scavalca prendi la veloce strappare la
nostra ora non sta volando per gli ex
non sto guardando il barattolo gigante
mi piace non l'avevo visto il bollettino
corrie cori ma prendili porca eva non
lascia lì per terra vai ce l'ho fatta
dove li ho lanciati io persi porca vacca
mi ha visto no non lo prendiamo perfetto
è però devo prendere come faccio gli
mettono nel carrello
wow è stato veramente difficile
cerca la pizza congelata la bene ma ci
sarà un'apertura signora mi deve proprio
camminare di fianco per favore grazie a
entrarci tour va bene mi devo fare il
giro di tutto il congelatore per
prendere la pizza ma va siete pazzi
devo entrare nel congelatore io va bene
questa non è proprio una cosa easy da
fare però ok perfetto no no aspetta non
devo ripartire dall'inizio rosa in pizza
perfett
che schifo fa la frase in pizza tra
l'altro io non ho mai mangiato in vita
mia la pizza surgelata e credo che mai
lo farò per ora cerca la mela perfetta
il reparto mele eccola la vedo la vedo
sale c'erano delle banane per terra mi
servirebbe questa qui prendi del latte
al cioccolato storica che casino fatto
in un solo posto ma questa la teoria se
cose lei sto prendendo ma dove le sto
mettendo perché non c'è il carrello
perché quel formaggio con la pac man per
riuscire a prendere quello dietro dietro
dietro dietro bertogli ecco that milk
company finito sushi omaggio sushi
omaggio come minimo cioè la salmonella
ma c'è minecraft qua c'è il reparto
minecraft che malati di mente hanno mai
in the craft lo sto vedendo il dio mio
ok non facciamoci domande però va bene
in questi crossover mi piacciono da
morire
se riuscissi a trovare il suo show
maggio dove il sushi maggio scorso dove
il retro ai laggiù mi scusi signora non
volevo che mentali tentacoli in faccia e
raga io lo vedo che c'è il mio nemico
dietro se scatole non è che mi potete
fare il jump square perché l'ho già
visto si intravede già anzi anno non
posso sfondare la statura vera ma almeno
semi cucini fi del sushi buono non
prezzo moderato maledizione vice k
cavalca le banane e muovendo il casinò
fortunatamente sommo vermi bene il suo
gioco almeno quello ciao tesoro no e
stavo facendo
conoscenza con il cuoco niente niente a
posto
scendete che dobbiamo pagare tutto sulla
cassa come è possibile
questa è la casa amica letta no
[Musica]
ecco 12 45 ok un borbottio trionfante
paquet a bruno il blu va bene tesoro
vero all'acquario solo perché ti amo ma
da quanto triste o mio dio quanto
spaventato dall acquario borbottii
disperati di terrore a noi a gli
scienziati noi riconosciamo gli animali
marini quando ne vediamo uno
spaventatissimo che bello premi un
coupon da scarlett a questo è il cubo
aspetta aspetta scusa tesoro preso a
riscatta il biglietto di ingresso va
bene permesso
devo devo riscatta aia porca vacca morta
n e non riesco a passare perché ma e
vabbè stai godendo di questa cosa salve
tocca a me tocca a me ho fatto tutto il
giro ecco qua buona permanenza grazie
permesso scusi i biologi marini di
conoscono un pesce quando ne vedono uno
meglio che rimane fuori dal campo visivo
va bene perché gli altri ovviamente non
vedono che sono un polipo solo gli
studiosi lo capiscono
ciao questo è il ticket abbiamo passato
metterlo lì ok ticket chi che cercava
che mai aveva mai che vado anch'io eh
dovevi largo in porca vacca sono la
marmotta sono una marmotta arcavacata
sono un mostro marino vive di eccomi qua
sono proprio il mostro marino più bello
che tu abbia mai visto passo perfetto
non possono guardarmi proprio diventati
sono mi dicono lo scova vero amore
possiamo passare aspetta aspetta aspetta
acqua vacca stai ferma che non capì
cerca scorsi scalette tommy siete qua
trovate io seguo mia moglie per prima
poi bambini li cerchiamo dopo vai a
parlare con scarlett amore cosa stai
facendo bene sono giochi che figata
dimmi tutto per una volta siamo senza
bambini va e cosa hai bisogno
ma adesso all'acquario dobbiamo parlare
porta 7 premi oscar le proviamo a
vincere sette premi per mia moglie è
visto che l'unico modo per riabilitare
mio matrimonio
non posso entrare dentro farli forio
butta giù tutto tutto quel tipo sta
imbrogliando no non è vero non è vero
dove dove stiamo pregando ma cena per
uno qui perfetta
e questo il premio 1 amore quello il
primo dei sette premi che ti devo
portare aspetta che bello il mio lavoro
da youtuber vi giuro io ogni giorno mi
alzo dico [ __ ] come sono contento
ok secondo premio amore questo è per te
lo prendi lo tieni ti prego prego devo
buttare giù la roba avere ma che figata
se giocando al contrario ma non sto
neanche guardando vado al culo a 20
frutti in 30 secondi ai ce la faccio se
ix20 all right che record che record
pensiamo a tre tutta un attimo come
faccio posso giocare a basket
bellissimo no geniale ma non ce la farò
mai tu vivrai e lesbiche bravo che sono
spetta quanti devo fare i canestri a 6
ma non esco a fare neanche uno no
veramente non puoi lanciare la palla
impossibile
porca vacca marta allora porco schifo 1
2 3 4 5 o almeno l'ultimo lo fa questi
giochi sono per bambini una guarda sono
stato un fenomeno credimi kobe bryant
sta piangendo
il micro centro subito di milano centro
subito o rai
raga ne mancano due e ogni secondo che
mi avvicino a mia moglie
questo si inventa sempre storie ridicole
a questo questo è facile 4 de pazzi tre
difficili chi ce l'ha fatta
siamo già a 10 allora mica vinto 20
volte perfetto fatemi fare l'ultimo ok
dram che giorno stupito di pensare che
se gioca vinto anche un botto di premi
c'è veramente o lo giuro e se li merita
tutti a mio avviso è l'ultimo e questo
ok è mio zio 7 te ne ho presi come c'è
una perdita nella vasca io devo andar
sistema manco lavorassi qua ma scusami è
giusto da qua accontenta beh ovviamente
questo potrebbe essere un problema più
grosso provo a ficcarmi c dentro a devo
usare cupa un attimo
e vabbè allora basta aspetta aspetta
amore aspetta amori stiamo riparando la
vasca è un attimo cordata tesoro dove
siete supera il pavimento da dalt a devo
ballare ma dio mio
se va beh non so come sto facendo ma
regala il migliore difficilissimo ma dai
thank you
questo fa luce va bene dai la luce a
stessi tieni e ti volevo dalla luce
prendi questa e vai tu ti prego prego
esatto grande mia figlia grande mia
figlia illumina la statua misteriosa
subito toh guarda lo vedi faceva schifo
era una rana a salire la scala mobile
che va il contrario
questa è infatti pil avevo giu mica sto
sudando c'è io vorrei farvi vedere cosa
sto premendo porca vacca è
difficilissimo
ce l'ho fatta io ti ringrazio
usciamo perché veramente behold permesso
alla eccoti qua per una volta sono
d'accordo
gioca al gioco del mappamondo va bene
può fare o prendere così verdi
ma porca vacca difficilissimo no non
andare lì che poi non ti posso seguire
un casino salve
devo entrare qua c'è il mio figlio scusa
anche se avete delle domande ce le ho
anche io ma non posso darvi disposti
ragazzi ho fatto un cambio di maglietta
perché tutti i tentacoli mimì mimì mi
facevano sudare quindi mi pensavano le
ventose né sparito il figlio sono
scivolato via ma mio figlio esperti ma
come fai a essere lì permesso
fatemi uscire che non voglio tratto ho
preso un cappello come più gioco sta
roba ragazzi in più di mento stupido in
realtà e funziona così quindi ragazzi
questa è la seconda episodi
ecco lo sapevo che non avrei non avrei
riuscito a dirlo io non avrei riuscito a
dire il nome c'è quello a carenze nelle
movenze io carenze nell'italiano però va
beh spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
come si vede cento antonio migliaccio
che invece ci sia se non siete non ci
vediamo
[Musica]